about eight weeks ago i got an email
from somebody who said i read your boy
crisis book it was really helpful to me
as a result of that i did not kill
myself and i did not do the mass
shooting i was planning to do i wrote a
52-page manifesto about the mass
shooting i was planning but i was
brought up by a mom and i was brought up
by two aunts and a grandmother and none
of them had any men in their lives and i
had no man in my life he hated his mom
and by extension he hated all women and
so he then ended up getting involved
with 4chan and hm which are basically
neo-fascist type of groups in h and two
of those people in hn have already
committed major mass shootings and i
said well what attracted you to 4chan
and hr and he said
now in retrospect after i read the boy
crisis what i'm seeing is i had no
structure i had no father figure i had
no sense of purpose well look at this
you saved lives warren i mean it's
tragic that it has come to that where
your book about the christ among boys
might have spoken to someone and
kept them from doing something terrible
one of the things that i found about
angry men or angry women in the couple's
communication workshop
anger
is
vulnerability's
mask
most every time you see somebody that is
angry you can ask a different question
how are they hurt
what is their vulnerability
and if you ask that question you begin
to listen to their pain
and when you listen to their pain
don't argue with them about their pain
but just let them know what you hear
that they said
and you will see an enormous reduction
in their anger
that's the way to deal with angry people
not by making them into horrible human
beings that you hate because hate met by
hate only increases hate
[Music]
this week on forward the author of the
boy crisis why our boys are struggling
and what we can do about it dr warren
farrell
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to the
podcast
the author of the boy crisis why our
boys are struggling and what we can do
about it dr warren farrell
warren thank you so much i am just
looking so forward to talking with you
so you came to this work
by helping women i want to say
you were
working with a national organization of
women you were elected to the board of
directors their new york chapter several
times
you then want to work in the
obama administration on gender issues is
that all correct yes and the obama
administration reached out when they
formed the council for women and girls
and asked me to be on their advisory
board but they ended up never creating
that advisory board and when they asked
me that i i said we also need a white
house council on boys and men and they
said oh well you know submit a proposal
so i submitted a very extensive proposal
getting experts from all over the world
to contribute to it and they never let
it off the ground we had the boy scouts
endorsing it and ready to present it to
president obama standing outside his
office two minutes before the meeting
valerie jarrett came up and said no no
let's take this off the agenda and it
didn't allow us to present it and never
did allow it to get anywhere that is
very disheartening um so let's rewind a
bit further back how did you come to the
set of issues and what did you get your
phd in i got my phd in political science
and but while i was doing my
dissertation i was teaching at rutgers
university and i was so excited about
the women's movement the students told
me you know warren you've got to do your
dissertation and you know in something
related to women's issues and so i
changed my dissertation topic so that
led ultimately long story short
to my getting elected to the board of
directors of the national organization
for women in new york city and starting
some 300 men's groups around the country
and some 250 women's groups every speech
i would go to i'd pass out yellow pads
have people sign up for women's or men's
groups the main focus of a men's group
is you must have everything be
confidential and once men trusted the
confidentiality
all sorts of stories poured out of them
that made me also have empathy for men
so when i started integrating the male
perspective and the female perspective
for my audiences i began to notice the
enthusiasm was less than it was when i
was just uh
when i was only talking about the uh
women's perspective oh well warren
what's your personal family situation do
you have kids yourself no two girls uh
which is ironic and um and i'm married
and been together with my wife for 28
years uh so
you a grandfather as well if your
daughter's had kids i'm a grandfather of
a grandson yes you know it kind of makes
sense too because you started down this
path as a
champion of women in part probably
because you know you had two daughters
and you saw some of their experiences
and then uh you know you
realized that
uh that boys uh and men had issues as
well now it's quite a progression you've
had and you document some of the
men's stories that opened up your sense
of empathy in the book so you and i met
when you interviewed various
presidential candidates in iowa right
after your book came out uh in 2018 is
that right yeah so the boy crisis had
just come out and as i was mentioning to
you beforehand you were of the eight
presidential candidates i interviewed
you were the only one who really knew it
without my having to
introduce the material the others were
oh interesting or barely paid attention
and you just went right on and you know
as if you had written the book with me
it was really very impressive no i was
aware of the problem among boys and men
from the research i did in my
book the war on normal people that came
out in 2018
so you and i think we're barking up the
same tree doing research in 2017 and the
numbers around boys and men i found
staggeringly
uh difficult and challenging and
depressing
uh and i believe that they were being
compounded by the economic
transformation of the fourth industrial
revolution the easiest example i would
draw was that look
two-thirds to three-quarters of
manufacturing workers are or were men we
eliminated five million manufacturing
jobs
so that's disproportionately going to
affect men primarily in midwestern and
southern states
if you have an extra one two three
million unemployed men
then you're going to see some serious
problems arise
in lockstep with that has been a decline
in marriage rates among
people without college degrees
nationwide it's gone from 70 percent
in the 80s or 70s to uh 45 percent today
uh and that's a number that really hurt
me because getting married seems like
something that a lot of people in my
mind at least when i was growing up you
kind of projected for yourself like you
thought hey i'm gonna you know mature
get a job get married so the fact that
that's less than a 50 50 proposition for
the majority of americans really hurt my
heart absolutely well you sort of you
and i are very oriented towards
solutions so each of those fortunately
has solutions so this in japan
about 25 of the student population
goes to vocational school the people who
graduate from vocational school which is
almost all the ones that that enter the
vocational school track
99.6
of them get employed
today we are not training boys to for ai
for all the new um evolution of
vocations that are coming up all of
these are doable as japan is proving and
all of these leave boys with a sense of
purpose when they graduate and of course
girls too but it's disproportionately
boys that are dropping out of high
school and a boy that drops out of high
school
is more than 20 likely to be unemployed
boys today 66 percent more likely to be
living in their parents basement or
living with their parents after college
or after high school and then we do
their female counterparts and i don't
know any of my female friends or my
daughters they don't search unemployment
lines and they don't search boys living
at home for their future husbands and as
you said in your your last podcast um
with zach when you were graduated from
law school and decided not to pursue
that and you for your first two jobs
were not super successful you didn't
have that confidence inside of yourself
nor were women as interested in you and
you sort of sensed that and it wasn't
until you really succeeded and then you
met evelyn that you started to sort of
feel a different type of energy that led
to your marriage the focus on vocational
education on boys achieving
these are things that allow women to
look for these type of men
and when they don't find those type of
men they decide eventually to have
children without being married 50 of
women under 30 who have children are not
married and about 42
of women overall are not married and
marriage is not as big an issue until
you look at the fact that the people
even who are living together women who
are men who are living together that
aren't married those relationships only
last an average of two and a half to
three years which then means the boy
feels abandoned doesn't have a role
model the girl doesn't have a role model
and girls and boys who don't have a
father significant father involvement do
worse on more than 70 different metrics
of success and happiness
as they're growing up and boys more so
more intensely so than girls
yeah that's one of the defining
elements of the boy crisis that you
outline in your book and your book is
chock full of data and statistics as
someone who likes that stuff i found it
very very
compelling
so here's a fun fact 90 of coffee from
the grocery store is actually stale
you heard that right the coffee you know
and think you love needs an upgrade so
instead of rebuying the same old same
old let trade coffee send you something
freshly roasted they are literally by
the numbers guaranteed to love so trade
sells the freshest roasted and ethically
sourced beans from america's best
independent roasters so they ship it to
you free as often as you like whole or
ground so if you love coffee this is the
place for you so whether you're a coffee
nerd or just love a better daily cup
trades real coffee experts taste test
over 400 roasts and use tech to match
you to your ideal coffee based on your
preferences and brewing method it's
pretty freaking cool i took the quiz
found out all these different types of
light roast and where it's from the
types of coffee that i like and it's
been great and it comes to me i brew it
up and it's wonderful and frankly you
could save money doing this instead of
spending you know four dollars for a cup
of coffee and some of the places
where we can get let's call it your fast
food coffee if you will this is better
ethically sourced made at home awesome
coffee so right now trade coffee is
offering a total of 20 off your first
three bags when you go to
drinktrade.comyang so to get started
take their quiz at
drinktrade.comhang and start your
journey to your perfect cup that's
drinktrade.com for 20 off your first
three bags check it out
[Music]
um so i wrote a recent op-ed in the
washington post and i i laid out a bunch
of facts that i thought painted a fairly
uh bleak picture where boys are more
than twice as likely to be diagnosed
with adhd than girls more than five
times as likely to find themselves in
juvenile detention
are
much less likely to graduate from high
school if they do go to college
they will find themselves comprising
only 40.5 percent of college students
which is a real minority at this point
uh if you don't go to college uh then
you're struggling to find a job and this
economy um income for men has declined
in real terms since 1990 almost 15
percent of male community college
students dropped out in 2020 alone which
was a mind-boggling stat
about one-third of all men are either
out of the job market or unemployed or
have dropped out in some form or fashion
that number is
mind-blowing uh you can go down the list
and see that that there are a lot of uh
very very tough statistics including the
fact that now
deaths of despair among middle-aged men
are reaching
record and unprecedented levels so if
you trace it from boyhood to manhood to
adulthood to
growing up um it all looks rough and to
your point
that there's a circularity because
unfortunately if you have men who are
failing
then you have a lot of kids growing up
without dads and it turns out that
having a dad uh is a very very positive
thing for positive outcomes i have to
say warren it made me feel uh good about
myself just in that i'm a dad and you
know i'm around i mean i actually don't
consider myself like a dad of the year
candidate or anything like that um and
you know i feel self-conscious about
that but the the the data shows that
well you know just my being here is like
a huge net positive
um so those are some of the things that
i use to outline uh the
magnitude and depth of the boy crisis uh
if you're trapped in an elevator with
someone and they say hey boy crisis like
what do you mean what do you say to them
i say boys all around the world and all
56 of the largest developed nations are
falling behind girls
in every single academic subject
especially in reading and writing doing
well in reading and writing is the
single biggest academic predictor of
success and our daughters you know they
want to have somebody worthy of them to
marry women are not interested in
marrying men who are unemployed who are
not
doing well educationally who are not
doing well success supplies so this is
an international phenomenon
and you define in your book a number of
major issues and hurdles and one that i
think a lot of people are
sensing but you put a name to
is what you call the purpose void
uh where where boys are concerned
describe what you mean yes um
historically speaking
every generation had its war
and and during that period of time we
said to to boys young boys you know
uncle joe there he joined the marines
and we're really proud of him and the
boy would learn that if he even though
he was being criticized at home and he
maybe he wasn't great at school
nevertheless he could be a hero he could
really be something if he risked his
life at that war
so each generation trained its boys to
define masculinity as risking
disposability of their life if they
didn't risk disposability in war then
they risk disposability in a more subtle
way in the workplace what i mean by that
is when men and we often hear about the
pay gap between men and women there is
actually not a pay gap between men and
women per se the pay gap is between dads
and moms because when dads and moms
become dads and moms moms reduce the
amount of intensity of their work
load outside of the home and increase
the amount of intensity inside the home
and men who want to be a musician or an
actor an artist or an elementary school
teacher and do something really
fulfilling to them
they realize that the fulfilling
occupations by and large pay less hence
starving artists so men give up the
glint in their eyes their dream and they
go off instead of being an elementary
school teacher they become a
superintendent of schools something
along those lines and then we as
feminists were criticizing men as having
the power because they were earning more
money
or they were the superintendent of
schools even though there were more
women in education without realizing
that that was the sacrifice that men
made it was not male privilege and male
power men gave up their dream the glint
in their eyes what they really wanted to
do
to be able to do something that would
lead to their children having
opportunities that they didn't have so
for example i met a cab driver but he
drove 70 plus hours a week and i asked
him you know why do you drive that much
and he said well i wanted to put my
daughter through college because nobody
in our family has ever gone to college
and i think my daughter's pretty smart
i'm making this sacrifice so that she'll
have an opportunity to be something that
i would have loved to be but i need to
do the cab driving to make that happen
well she got into uc santa cruz and he
told me that when she came back from uc
santa cruz after her first holiday
she said you know dad i didn't realize
this but you know you are part of the
patriarchy and you are you are really
more of an oppressor and she had all
these words for me that
made me feel like
everything i'd done to sacrifice for the
last um you know 20 25 35 years
was a waste and i didn't feel loved
appreciated or heard and so many men
feel that today but until they get into
a men's group and they see
that lots of other men feel the same way
they just keep those feelings to
themselves and they don't articulate
them to themselves
women can't hear what men don't say so
women don't realize that they see men
getting into higher positions but they
don't see the karoshi they don't see
which is the japanese word for
death at the desk or death from overwork
the japanese in fact have a game that
they play called karoshi and the person
who they compete to get to the top of
the of the corporate ladder or the
political ladder or the religious letter
and the person who gets to the top of
the ladder first
commits
suicide because the young japanese
millennials realize that
men climbing to the top of the ladder is
not power
it's becoming a human doing rather than
becoming a human being and becoming a
human being doing what you want to do
doing what fulfills you doing what the
women's movement has taught women to do
that's power that's real power
this is the new understanding of real
power but when that isn't understood and
there aren't
lots of fathers involved this purpose
void
that was men's
willingness to define themselves as men
by being the sole breadwinner or being
willing to die in war
this we no longer need so many men to
die in war and many more women are
helping with the breadwinning
so the boys they don't have their old
senses of purpose
[Music]
okay you guys need to stop
sleeping on terrible mattresses and i've
been there before i've had a mattress
like oh it's not that bad it's fine it's
tolerable i got a helix sleep mattress
and it has changed my life it's changed
my back it's changed my sleep it's
changed my mental health it's changed my
energy because a good night's sleep
works wonders so look helix sleep has
this very simple quiz you can just take
two minutes complete it matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
want a mattress made for anyone else
makes sense with helix you get a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you sleep and they know that
so you have soft medium firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot they have mattresses great
for spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains they even have a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers
like you've got
all your options so i took the helix
quiz i got the mattress i needed it fits
me and it's fantastic so if you're
looking for a mattress take the quiz
order the mattress that you're matched
to and the mattress comes right to your
door shipped for free in this little
highly packaged box and it's wonderful
you never need to go to the mattress
store again so here you go go to
helixsleep.com yang take their two
minute sleep quiz and they'll match you
with a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life 10
year warranty you get to try it out free
for 100 nights risk-free totally awesome
and right now they are offering up to
200 off all mattresses and two free
pillows for our listeners so that's
helix sleep.com
yang so check it out helix sleep.com
yang
[Music]
what do you recommend as trying to fill
the purpose for it let's say that
historically boys have been soldiers and
uh breadwinners is what you're
suggesting and then there's less of a
need for the former and unfortunately
tougher paths to the latter
uh so what
is a possible substitute and the first
thing that came to mind for me was video
games where it's i'm which is not a
great substitute but it's like you know
it's like they'll give you
a you know digital version of certainly
being a soldier or
a breadwinner because you know you'll
like earn points and
gold and status there's two major
solutions i would say
one is understanding
what dads contribute to the home and to
the family
that moms can contribute that every
single mom listening to this can do
these things but dads tend to do these
things these things are things like
roughhousing teasing taking them on
adventures um letting them take risks
the risks that aren't likely to to kill
them
but risk that that allow them to get
lost that allowed them to make mistakes
taking them to the playground leaving
them with other kids in the playground
as opposed to
sitting there constantly watching them
the child is more likely to get into a
fight on the playground without the mom
or dad around but the father when the
father can process and talk with the
child about you know what did you you
know what what led you to understand
that you might get into a fight there um
you know one of the kids there was a
bully what led you to understand that
he's a bully well he was drinking he was
pushing other people around uh he was
fouling people and you know doing those
things and so what could you have done
that was different than what you did
well i guess i could have left yes you
could have left but they may have called
me a chicken so
talk to me about what it's like to be
called a chicken and why why are you
afraid to be called a chicken and so on
and what takes more courage giving into
being called a chicken or actually being
able to walk away
when you're being called a chicken and
not being controlled by those names um
and or rough housing for example
dads are far more likely than moms to
roughhouse i'm happy to say warren i
read a study early on that roughhousing
is good for
development of boys so as a result i
mess with my boys regularly if they're
outbreaking is good for their brain
development and it's also good for
something that's extremely
counterintuitive which is empathy
you have two sons if you're you know
roughhousing with both of them at the
same time maybe um chris will do
something that is not what you want him
to do
and you make it clear probably that you
know if you continue to do that there's
not going to be any more rough housing
now that your children have to decide
are they going to push the other one
aside
and then lose their rough housing and
when you make it so that when they push
the somebody else aside or don't
are not empathetic to the needs of
their brother
that that's going to be the end of the
rough housing and when they know they're
going to lose the rough housing
that's that's the boundary enforcement
that teaches them to focus on postponed
gratification
not the immediate gratification of just
pushing their brother out of the way
but the postponed gratification of um
getting the rough housing by not pushing
their brother out of the way which
teaches them that somebody else here is
important besides them and then and it
also teaches them the difference between
assertiveness and aggressiveness
so in that process you're teaching them
postpone gratification empathy
social skills that lead them to to doing
much better at school
teaching the boy postponed gratification
then allows him to be able to achieve
whatever new sense of purpose he wants
now with with a father and mother
involved uh one of the things that we
have is a chance for for the future
is to be able to
do something very different than we did
with boys historically historically we
said you know disposable at war
disposable at work now we can say
who are you what makes you shine what
makes you fulfilled what makes you feel
wonderful about yourself and if it's
something like being a musician an
artist an actor which takes a high only
a small percentage succeed
helping our sons understand that you not
only need the dream so the dream
is a potential new sense of purpose
but the dream becomes a great
disappointment if you don't have the
discipline to fulfill your dream
when boys and girls go out and they are
told that they're great at something but
they don't have the discipline to
fulfill it
after a while the failure that is
associated with each new dream becomes
so great that they're afraid to dream
and that's deeply sad and then and then
they often turn to drugs or to drinking
or in boys cases in particular to
suicide so at the age of nine boys and
girls commit suicide equally between the
ages of 10 and 14
boys suicide rate is twice that of girls
between between that of 15 and 19 is
four times out of girls and between the
ages of 20 and 24
it is five times out of girls the people
who are most likely to commit suicide
both boys and girls are boys and girls
without dads
and because often times that
loss of having being able to fulfill
this new sense of purpose
and the disappointment in oneself and
the lack of discipline
leads to the boys and the girls feeling
disappointed in themselves and they
don't have as many friends in school
they don't get as much praise from
teachers or even from their parents and
they become depressed suicidal drinking
drugs and as we know i i know you know
boys are more than twice as likely to
die from opiate overdoses as as girls
are my personal journey on this warren
it's interesting i was reflecting just
now where like i felt this massive
pressure to do something significant uh
and
uh make a certain amount of money so i
could start a family at some point
and i discovered entrepreneurship which
by the way was very difficult and i
flopped a couple of times
um but it really is a very good fit for
this
quest for purpose because
you're
building something you're working with
others you're solving a problem
uh there were many many times when i
would go out there and do something
uh like let's say
just something spraying my mind where
like i got a message from
a university in texas saying hey we're
looking for like a supplier of
uh certain type of class
and then i
uh said oh i could be there tomorrow now
was i planning on being there of course
not but i just
like got on a plane and went out and had
a meeting and like tried to get a
contract
and there there was like a sense of
soldiering or adventuring in its own way
where it was like you're out there
trying to
conquer new ground by getting new
customers or in our case we would expand
to a new market um so it was an
excellent fit for me i i and i started
an organization that's trying to
cultivate entrepreneurs because i
instinctively felt like it would be a
great fit for a lot of people i dare say
that that's the kind of thing that would
fill a void for a lot of boys girls
anyone you know anyone who wants to to
try and find some kind of purpose and
significance now that said
it's extraordinarily difficult to
actually start a business or enterprise
organization of any kind
and so the best recommendation i had to
a lot of folks was to join
uh an organization
or company that was trying to do
something interesting or significant
because you'll learn i mean what
happened to me is i started a company
and it failed and then i joined two
startups as the lieutenant and then
eventually became the ceo of another
working with more experienced builders
and mentors like i got better and
stronger myself so that's what i
recommended to a lot of people but
everything i'm describing is not
directly accessible for the average
person who's just you know like coming
out of high school or community college
or college and being like oh where do i
find this opportunity and even if you
did show up that you know like that the
company may or may not have a need for
someone with uh you know like like that
particular profile but that that was my
vision my hope um in part i think
because i sensed this purpose void
in myself that i managed to fill
but i sense that
it would be an enormous boon if we could
help fill it for others one of the great
things the women's movement has done is
to sort of
understand that a decent percentage of
women
want to have this sort of sense of
purpose too my my wife works at 60 70
hours a week even though she's
in her late 60s and i'm trying to get
her to you know slow down a little bit
and not stress out so much but she gets
this enormous sense of purpose
from from working that hard and from you
know fulfilling her clients needs and so
on
and at the same time we have to realize
both
boys and girls have an enormous need to
achieve but
males have a second layer on that we
often say that you know men have a great
need to do something that is significant
that proves themselves
but what very few people get
is that a lot of motivation on our part
as men
is we what we really want is love
we know that when lois lane had no
interest in clark kent but she fell in
love with superman
so we know that when we succeed there's
much greater likelihood that a woman
will be interested in us my argument
along these lines was look
there are certain jobs that have very
very high market rewards associated with
them let's call it being a ceo or
something along those lines um and so
then women look up and say hey we should
be more ceos and then i look at that and
say that's almost certainly correct
because uh you know like you would be
great and the rest of it um but there
there are there's a significant part of
me that's like maybe we should be trying
to change the entire economic system
itself so that it's not just that
certain types of behaviors get outsized
economic rewards and the primary
challenge shouldn't be hey we should
make the winner circle more
representative it's like hey maybe we
should broaden what it means to be a
winner maybe you could be a winner by
you know being like a good person taking
care of folks like in in your own home
or in your neighborhood or community
maybe we need to
redefine economic success
in various ways
or even success as a human which is
something that you refer to i believe as
heroic intelligence versus health
intelligence is that accurate accurate
and basically i'm saying like with the
kiroshi example that i gave before that
you know they're climbing to the top of
a ladder
and unbecoming who you really want to be
not being that elementary school teacher
that musician that artist that writer
what did you want to be when you were a
kid warren well i i started to stand out
in writing when i was in high school but
my father made it clear when i wanted to
take off instead of shelving snow i
wanted to go to the library to write a
book in high school
he said you know first of all warren you
need to shovel the snow second
second
i just want to warn you that only about
1 out of 100 people who write a book
even get that book published and if you
can't get a publisher you'll never get a
wife and you'll never have a family um
so he was making it clear to me he was
born in 1910 when he was 35 he'd been
through two world you know world wars
and
a depression and from his perspective
life was about um you know making sure
you were responsible that you fulfilled
obligations and it was not about doing
what you want to do i wanted to be a spy
like james bond oh really
yeah yes yes
there's the ultimate hero and and it's a
good example of heroic intelligence
versus health intelligence the average
person doing what james bond does for
more than six or seven minutes is likely
to be called dead instead of going to
his funeral back to your point yes we
need to redefine what it is to be a
success
we can help our children define their
sense of purpose and get the discipline
to do that they need father involvement
because the balance between being a
mother and a father creates a checks and
balance parenting that leads to so many
boys and girls doing so much better when
they have both the discipline and the
nurturance and the discipline and the
nurturing back and forth
[Music]
ask yourself right now how is your
mental health
is something preventing you from
achieving your goals is something
interfering with your happiness
i want you guys to check out
betterhelp.com
yang
i did this myself
i got a therapist
mental health coach and someone i could
confide in and talk about what i'm going
through on a daily basis and it was
game changing life-changing i'd say so
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely online so check out better
help you can send a message to your
counselor anytime you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses and plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
whatever is convenient for you so you're
talking about depression or stress or
anxiety or relationships or sleeping
trauma you name it anything you share is
confidential convenient professional and
affordable so i want you to start living
a happier life today so as a listener
you're going to get 10 off your first
month by visiting our sponsor
betterhelp.com
yang so join over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
again that's better help help dot com
slash yang
[Music]
one of the things i said when i was
running for president is that we should
try and keep families together because
two-parent families just have much
better outcomes among kids
i think i got a little bit of heat for
that even though that that's just like a
factual
uh
relationship the most important single
thing for keeping families together is
communication and the single biggest
achilles heel of all human beings is our
inability to handle personal criticism
without becoming defensive the last 30
years i've been focusing on doing
couples communication workshops so that
i could teach people how to handle the
criticisms their partner has
by
altering their biologically natural
state of becoming defensive
and creating a safe environment for
their partner to say whatever was on
their mind and that keeps marriages
together not by legislation but by
communication if you don't have
marriages stay together
usually the divorces lead to the father
becomes less involved the mother wants
the fatherless involved the mother falls
in love sometimes with a new man
they may be moved to a new new place out
of state mother often if she fights it
she has the right to children often
times men have to fight for children and
the children end up without
without their father in their life what
can be done as a solution to that is a
possibility of a father warrior program
where we say to men
one of your new senses of purpose
is not to kill and be killed as in the
past but to love and be loved and who
needs you to love and be loved first of
all mothers do single moms are
overwhelmed they're torn between their
jobs and not doing that well enough and
their children
and we have men out there fathers who
have no sense of purpose
who are not being taught to love and be
loved and we really need to make it part
of our national calling to say to men we
need you as we have in the past but we
need you to be fully involved with the
children here are the 70 plus reasons
things that happen
that are better for children when you
are involved
at this point being a man who wants to
contribute to the growth of the next
generation is extraordinarily high value
you know i know there's a waiting list
for months and months for someone to be
a big brother or mentor to
young boys who may have single moms
we should be putting more men in
position to contribute like that and
frame that as like the new struggle
because right now that's not happening
and it's having disastrous effects that
you and i have both documented and tried
to share with the world the most
important single thing you can do if
you're a single mom listening to this is
to
understand the differences between dad
style parenting and mom style parenting
dad style parenting is not well
explained understanding for example the
connection between rough housing and
empathy roughhousing and postponed
gratification
understanding the value of teasing and
also how important it is that you're
there so the teasing doesn't go too far
understanding the value of risk-taking
so all those things when you let a man
know that you see that he's needed for
these natural propensities that he tends
to display
men come when they are needed when they
are wanted and they disappear when
they're not make sure your son gets
involved in what i call the liberal arts
of sports
team sports
pick up team sports which is perfect
preparation for them to be an
entrepreneur you set your own boundaries
you pick people from the beginning you
discover who works and who doesn't work
and then also sports where you are the
the primary person to stand out like in
tennis or in gymnastics or downhill
skiing you're part of a team maybe the
emphasis is on you in those liberal arts
of sports all of them is important but
also attend them often enough to find
out which coach is likely to be the type
of coach that you'd like to have be a
good role model for your son
let the coach know that your son does
not have a good male role model involved
most coaches will bend over backwards to
be
more involved cub scouts boy scouts cub
scouts a lot of proven data showing that
what all of us and every mom that i've
ever spoken to cares about which is the
character development of her son
is enhanced enormously by consistent
involvement in the cub scouts for two or
more years boy scouts has deconstructed
masculinity in such a way as to reward
boys with merit badges and many many
rituals that lead to boys having that
sense of purpose and doing well
so take a look at the part of the boy
crisis that talks about the importance
of checks and balance parenting
value mom what you contribute and also
value what dad contributes and know that
your differences are not a sign that you
need to be divorced but your differences
are exactly what your children need if
negotiated in a way that allows both of
you to hear each other without becoming
defensive to the extent that there is a
popular movement around trying to help
boys and men in this way um you're the
first person i thought of and you you
wrote the book
um are there others i i feel like now
i'm one
[Laughter]
which i appreciate
what does the landscape look like i'm
curious as to what the the state of this
particular conversation is
first of all i would say read forward
read lettered sexes boys adrift read
everything that michael gorion has
written on boys these are some other
people as well that have really
contributed in this area
i hope the boy crisis i spent 14 years
researching and writing and i i'm very
solution oriented to the boy crisis i
made a commitment to myself to say
nothing that i couldn't solve
and and you know
i know you're very solution oriented as
well
and very data based as well
[Music]
okay so i'm guessing when you come out
with this book there are a lot of people
that immediately had a negative reaction
they try and paint you as something of
like a conservative men's right activist
type even though your background
suggests that you're very much not those
things
and then you have been working since
2018 for the last number of years you've
championed a council or committee on
boys and men at the white house level
which apparently the obama
administration was not interested in um
you're still championing that proposal
today right yes
what has your journey been like as uh
one of the most prominent people to make
this case uh first of all i'm more
politically liberal than i am
conservative uh although i often say to
my friends that i'm gonna write a book
called between a rock and a hard place a
lot of people feel the same way
when i went around and did the um
interviewing of the presidential
candidates um uh two or three of the
campaign managers said you know warren
my candidate really likes you but we
can't afford to alienate our feminist
base and the single mother is if you
tell them that boys are doing badly
they're going to feel criticized we
can't risk that and i felt so deeply sad
and when you when you formed the forward
party in the back of my mind i said um
he is feeling the pressure can't say
this if you're a republican you can't
say this if you're a democrat you're now
free to be able to say what you really
feel when you came out with
the washington post op-ed and the two
the tweets that suggested that there's a
real problem with men and boys i felt
you know maybe that was an example of
that as i started speaking on this issue
a number of people from the white house
did spot me and they asked me to come to
the white house to brief them on the boy
crisis book this is in the trump
administration continue the trump
administration right and i did and they
brought in people from hhs and from doj
department of justice and presidential
staff and they listened really
attentively to um what i had written in
the boy crisis and briefed them on and
then they asked me to write a speech
that president trump might give and i
did do that what didn't completely
surprise me because i had seen this
already is that the conservatives were
expressing a much
greater consciousness of the importance
of mothers and fathers the importance of
family and they had a sense of boys were
having a lot of challenges even though i
was not a fan of trump per se i saw much
greater receptivity on the part of
conservatives toward this issue
i saw much less interest on the part of
democrats unfortunately i had some hope
when biden was running for office that
he was forming this gender policy
council but unfortunately the gender
policy council was focused only on girls
and women and not on boys not on men not
on fathers and i've spoken to jen klein
about this who is the co-chair of the
gender policy council and her response
is oh president biden is a father he
cares about being a father he cares
about men
don't worry warren but i do worry
because you don't you don't say i just
care about something and and create no
policies so for example men as we both
know die five years sooner than women on
average and they die sooner of 19 out of
the top 20 causes of death but there is
no
federal office on men's health there is
seven federal offices on women's health
really it's unconstitutional it's a
violation of equal protection you you
and i are definitely raising the red
flag being like hey guys boys need help
men need help people are struggling
outcomes are terrible
uh and one of the points in my wampo
op-ed was like hey if men fail
it's going to be bad for men but it's
kind of bad for everyone because you
know like uh and and the most
conspicuous examples of male failure
unfortunately are going to be
violent uh that they're going to
be destructive
um one of the points that i made that
you probably heard is that if you have a
lot of men who are
in their basements uh being subject to
toxic ideologies some are going to be
radicalized some are going to show up
with with firearms in a country that has
hundreds of millions of firearms
and do terrible things so like all these
problems are tied together and this is
not mutually exclusive it's like look if
you want organizations that help women
i'm all for it uh you know like i i
think that maybe men should also have
the benefit of the same kind of uh
empathy and by the way a lot of the
problems that our country should be most
concerned about
are
related to male failure absolutely i got
a
about eight weeks ago i got an email
from somebody who said i read your boy
crisis book it was really helpful to me
as a result of that i did not kill
myself and i did not do the mass
shooting i was planning to do i wrote a
52-page manifesto about the mass
shooting i was planning but i was
brought up by a mom and i was brought up
by two aunts and a grandmother and none
of them had any men in their lives and i
had no man in my life he hated his mom
and by extension he hated all women and
so he then ended up getting involved
with 4chan and hm which are basically
neo-fascist type of groups in h and two
of those people in a chan have already
committed major mass shootings and i
said well what attracted you to 4chan
and hr and he said
now in retrospect after i read the boy
crisis what i'm seeing is i had no
structure i had no father figure i had
no sense of purpose well look at this
you saved lives
hopefully yeah i mean it's tragic that
it has come to that where your book
about the crisis among boys might have
spoken to someone and
kept them from doing something terrible
one of the things that i found about
angry men or angry women in the couple's
communication workshop
anger
is
vulnerability's mask
most every time you see somebody that is
angry you can ask a different question
how are they hurt
what is their vulnerability
and if you ask that question you begin
to listen to their pain
and when you listen to their pain
don't argue with them about their pain
but just let them know what you hear
that they said
and you will see an enormous reduction
in their anger
that's the way to deal with angry people
not by making them into horrible human
beings that you hate because hate met by
hate only increases hate
that's an incredibly profound lesson and
exactly the kind of thing i want to
make the customary reaction via forward
so you are
fighting for
uh
a white house commission on men and boys
is that right like what is your current
cause and work and how can someone keep
up with you and support you after you've
had a chance to read the boy crisis let
me know what is
of value to you about it and then i will
work with you to
be involved with the coalition to create
a white house council on boys and men
or encourage you to be involved with
helping boys there are so many things
that are potentially happening at school
potentially happening in mental health
there's an inventory of in the book of
63 red flags of depression and suicide
but you can help bring that into schools
you can teach young men how to
communicate so that they become prepared
to be great fathers that can communicate
with both women and their children and
teach their children great role models
of communication there's so many
opportunities out there and you know and
and really
follow what you are doing um because you
are the only national political person
that understands these issues and you've
articulated so much of it and forward
and um and really get involved with your
campaign and make it happen oh wow well
that's so kind right back at you warren
thank you for making me feel not crazy
[Laughter]
dr ward farrell the author of the boy
crisis why our boys are struggling and
what we can do about it he's a very very
solutions oriented
human and the book is as well thank you
so much warren this is maybe the most
important issue
in american life today uh and it's not
going anywhere um so you and i i'm sure
will will have plenty of chances to make
common cause
i look forward to that very much
[Music]